gotcha
no ok I'll be gentle now you know your
life is different now today it's time
for a good old-fashioned Q&A in fact
that's exactly what I've tweeted out
last night to get your questions with
the hashtag ask grace I got your cues
here are my eggs what's the worst advice
you've ever received only care about
what other people think of you listen to
every single youtube comment you've ever
gotten all gonna die someday so maybe
don't enjoy life you should go see the
movie daddy day care you have any really
bad food takes for example I like plain
yogurt on my spaghetti and I'm afraid to
put some mayonnaise on tacos we're
trying to get him help uh-oh we're back
sometimes I put code hummus on a cold
lock of tofu and I just eat it like it's
cake
I like the texture and I'm also just a
monster also have you wrapped like
strings of string cheese around Fritos
it's really good just a couple gourmet
tips for all those booties out there
what has been the biggest surprises
about this maquette creating reactions
hiring it's all been really surprisingly
wonderful I was worried that it would be
a huge jolt to my system having this
much more work to do on a weekly basis
but everyone's having a really great
time so maybe I'm just surprised that
we're out it was great
that shouldn't be surprising it should
be something you hope for it a zoom will
happen but you never know I'm surprised
that you guys are enjoying it so much I
don't to say have very low expectations
for the environment in which we are
existing on YouTube at the moment but
who does get my expectations off my
floor so I can vacuum later haha guys
haven't checked out the new show that
memory and are doing Monday through
Fridays Club this might get linked in
the description box below go check it
out
there's honestly so much worse stuff on
YouTube than it I can say that with
total confidence can you come back to
Europe please sure how did you become
such a fashion icon you tell me how
important was your education and
becoming a big youtuber asking for a
friend
well went to college for four years and
studied communications and contemporary
arts and now I work from home making
YouTube videos bottling up my feelings
seems like it really helped pears are
pineapples
I'm on spring break next week but my two
friends are going back to school next
week so I'll be alone what activities
should I do
yes I'm poor wallowing and soaking in a
metaphorical pool of your own depression
are two very free activities how old are
you older than you think you if you
could go back and be first to start any
youtube trend which one would you own
which one will you erase from the
internet forever uh pimple popping it
would erase forever I hate it so much
and if I could go back and own one
really go back and own that trendy
Channel Daily Grace is that it it's been
so long do you have any college advise
well with the same advice I would give
without anything sexual related try it
if you don't like it don't do it or do
it differently and that face that it can
get better
will we see harto on this might get does
a grace Helbig mom really get to wear
deodorant
yes favorite Queen on drag race season
10 so far awesome favorite queen of all
time oh I don't know who my favorite
queen is on this season of drag race so
far are you guys watching if so let me
know in the comments down below who you
are loving I can't
I'm still getting to know them but I
love Eureka I will just say it and I
think I mean I love Ben de la creme gee
I didn't know much about before
all-stars and I know she's a very
polarizing controversial Queen for what
she did I won't spoil anything for those
I haven't seen it yet but I think she's
just super funny and super talented and
very humble what's your favorite travel
snack vodka can you talk me out of
trying to cut myself bags Pacifica's
curly hair and bangs is an oxymoron look
here's what I realized no one can talk
you out of your own desire to cut your
own bangs you'd experience the pain for
yourself and hopefully eventually
realize the direct emotional correlation
that cutting your own bangs has with
your mental health not saying that
people that have bangs are not happy I'm
just saying at times in my life did I
cut my back going on what song best
describes food brands myth
I made my own captain tryhard shirt and
now my professor insists on calling me
captain during class it's fashion
supposed to do this look I'm sorry to
warn you that excellent fashion has a
lasting effect on people any good
Netflix movie shows to binge while on
spring break
I just finished wild bald country on
Netflix it's this docu-series
about this religious sector called teeth
thing campus community thing it's very
very good highly recommend I just
graduated college what do I do now panic
can you tell couse I love her
goose a stranger on the internet loves
you she's planning herself like a cat
very busy what inspires you to still
make YouTube content that I want to get
to do it you guys and having an open
dialog and just being able to
communicate and be dumb and hopefully
provide some form of entertainment also
just like the crippling pressure of
relevancy huh when are you coming back
to Australia next hopefully at some
point in the near too distant future
name of your sex tape turnoff or the
command and how you'd feel watching it
if you could give any celebrity a wedgie
who would it be I mean Donald Trump you
have to hey you imagine oh I imagined Oh
new book soon can we send any letter of
the alphabet or just qs f you JK c so
many letters to choose from I'm thinking
of starting YouTube channel where's a
good place to start on YouTube but there
you go guys there is my Q&A for you
today I hope you enjoyed it if you did
hit that thumbs up button and click the
bell notification once you've subscribed
to this channel so you get notified on
the upload videos because it's
consistently inconsistent and that's
part of the charm hope I don't know say
hi to the case hi gays gusta situ